all right when I'm David Griffin
resident comic book and video game guru
here to bring you another review of
arrow we're gonna do two reviews kind of
gonna mash them into one gonna look at
last week's episode of blind spot and
this week's episode of tremors - you
know I was standing episodes and arrow
through wondering where Michael is he's
feel a little bit under the weather and
last week I was out of town so again no
bad timing life gets in the way it's how
it is so just gonna be me this week so
if we can have some fun talking about
air this week I want to start off first
though by talking about three of maybe
the I guess characters have kind of been
pushed to the side characters that used
to be interesting that aren't really as
machine as I think they could be those
Pig characters are Laurel Diggle and
Moira Moira definitely in this week's
episode became a lot more essential now
that she's running for mayor and cuz you
know like when Malcolm Merlyn showed up
again this season he's back he knows
like okay he's back he's not dead and we
found out that you know she has some
connections to Ra's al Ghul you know
maybe she knows who he is like she can
get word to him like what's more his
game I mean she's playing the mom who
you know loves her kids and wants to do
better but like for what like what does
that all mean I mean is she really gonna
end up being the good person that she
wants to be or she got some dark side to
her I think she has a little bit of both
she's a very interesting character so it
was happy to see Moira kind of step up
this week have something interesting to
do but then let's move on to Diggle I
was you know like I said I was out of
town last week visiting family and I
watched episodes my dad and he had never
seen arrow before but he saw Diggle and
he looked at and he said well what does
this guy this dude he just stand around
and just kind of watch and I was like
that's a good point Diggle doesn't
really do much ever since the episode
littered earlier this season where you
know he and Ali went to that prison to
find Deadshot
since then Diggle hasn't been essential
to the story all he just kind of just
you know he kind of stands on the side
of the desk like this and just kind of
looks I mean that's that's all he does
he's not doing anything and I I loved it
I think Diggle is a great character the
first he doesn't get a lot of good
things to do this season diggle's kind
of used so which is just too bad I mean
I don't know what do you think I mean I
like Diggle you like Diggle would you
like to see him do more I know
Mike and I have kind of complained all
this in the past I thought maybe they're
gonna give them more but they haven't
also you know moving on from Digga let's
talk about Laurel
probably the biggest sort of probably
the most disappointing character of
arrow I would say this season Laurel has
been on a downward spiral drinking drugs
you know pushes away her dad won't even
go to the AAA meeting I mean just all
this negativity around her and but
what's it for I mean is she
you know Mike had a really good theory I
know some of you had shared that theory
now Laurel is tied to the comics could
she become black in there you know maybe
her sister all died I don't know maybe
she'll she needs something to do though
she needs I mean you know what do you
think about that theory she Laurel right
now it's just all over the place she has
nothing going for she's probably get
disbarred did she see her sister at the
end of the episode this week did she you
know I don't know she was kind of having
some weird visions was that her sister
can I come and save her will her sister
who is canary now will she survive the
end of the season we're loyal Laurel
probably you know take over and become
black canary later I don't know but
Laurel either needs to I don't want her
to die but she needs to do something to
get interesting again I don't know let
me know what you think I was liked it
always loved to hear your opinion so let
me know you think about laurels
character okay so let's get away from
the minor characters that have not been
that interesting lately to talk about
let's go to the ending first of this
episode it's probably the most
interesting parts let's talk about
Amanda Waller Cynthia died Robinson aka
Naevia aka new via from Spartacus lover
glad she's on this show as Amanda Waller
she is going to form the Suicide Squad
and she's gonna start off with bronze
tiger Michael Jai White a KA spawn for
those of you who remember that kind of
awful movie with John because I don't
but that's okay so this story it's cool
to see Amanda wall talk about forming
the squad she didn't call it the Suicide
Squad but you know that's what Amanda
Waller does least in the comics nowadays
you know she is the head of you know the
Suicide Squad which for those of you who
don't know is a group of super villains
who Amanda Waller hires to you know they
want like a reduced sentence time in
prison you know work for me you know
they're kind of antihero I was like do
some good and we'll see
you know goes from there so okay let's
pull back and I'm jumping around a lot
here but this is so much everything you
know kind of ties in you know how arrow
goes just builds and builds and build
its go last week to a blind spot and I
think probably the biggest shocker of
that one was a reveal of destro even
though of course we know Slade Wilson is
in Sterling City we know that we told it
at the midseason finale so we know he's
around but it was cool we finally got to
see him all in the I guess you want to
call it contemporary was it orange and
gray militant suit you know we see it in
Batman Arkham origins for those of you
played that game we see it and injustice
gods among us you know the new fighting
game from DC so it was great to see men
who've been that you know another
Spartacus veteran Slade Wilson dressed
all in the orange and gray that was just
a great look for him he looked great in
the outfit
really cool this season this keeps you
know building and building doing a
better job I know that Michael and I
know a lot of you too
kind of complained a little bit and
didn't really enjoy the first I would I
guess you're gonna call what the
mid-season premiere about three weeks
ago
the episode was I guess a little bit
weaker I think these two have stepped it
up especially this newest one really
stepped it up just so many good things I
mean we're running for mayor what is
that gonna mean okay so I guess the next
big thing let's talk about Roy Roy
Harper is you know he's on a rampage I
mean a dude's got you know all that
venom flowing inside of them he's angry
you know doing like Slade Wilson is on
the island like we know we do the
flashbacks to man you and see him what
he's going through
Roy's going through that too and again
another another big reveal imagine that
a big reveal on arrow is Roy now knows
who Oliver is he knows that Oliver Queen
is arrow he's met the team you know I
mean you know they you know I love
Oliver's little thing about saying he
knows like we don't call ourselves team
arrow but you know of course you know
that's their name they are team arrow
you know they have a team they have a
squad hopefully Diggle will do something
in the squad a goal again that's been
disappointment for me
Moira stepping up though Laurel I don't
know I could kind of leave her right now
do you think there's redemption for do
you think they're gonna like you think
they're just bringing her low just to
build her back up make her Black Canary
10th of the season I don't know I I want
to talk about - before we wrap this up
about Deathstroke and I
think this season and I'm sure many
probably some of you agree with me is
leading up to a death stroke and arrow
you know big battle tee and a big clash
at the end but what I wonder is in that
clash could destro kind of you know not
has to die but maybe come back from that
cuz that's what was kind of one was in
between guys like sometimes he's good
sometimes he's bad he's an antihero for
sure he's not always just like a pure
bag he's not the Joker it's not the
ultimate bad guy so maybe man do Banette
can stick around even after let's say
like Ali and him fight at the end I hope
that they keep Deathstroke around he's a
really cool character again you know
switching stuff again or bounce around a
lot let's go back to last week episode
you know and let's talk about brother
blood who has been interesting cared
he's kind of off the hook now in terms
of people not thinking he's guilty he
set one of his boys in there to take the
fall for him to make a sacrifice but we
know that he's under the thumb of
Deathstroke Deathstroke has him in its
grip but who was destro who was Slade
Wilson working for who was meant to be
networking for we kind of know the
hierarchy right now I think Ra's al
Ghul's behind all of this I'm just gonna
put it out there I mean man who could be
working for himself but I think behind
this I think Ra's al Ghul is gonna show
up at some point maybe next season I
don't know that overcast and of course
with the flash pilot coming out in the
fall of 2014 which should be awesome
can't wait to see that so I mean that's
that's that's most of it that's that I
know there's so much stuff to talk about
all these guys like to point and gals
like to point out Easter eggs for Mike
and I so please share some more Easter
eggs from the episode there's one that I
saw I think the city or the town no
sorry the country the made-up country in
Europe is called markovia that the
terrorist was selling the earthquake
merlyn's earthquake device to and that's
a an actual you know a fictional
creation that dc-dc has always crazy
name for all these you know foreign
countries and so that was the one those
little Easter eggs you know share your
Easter eggs with Mike and I of course
we'll be back next week to give another
review as always but you know again I
always like to hear your thoughts on
this week's episode of arrow and of
course last week's as well as always
you'll come chat with us I'm think here
calm I can also find us on this YouTube
page right here I think here or Pro you
know comment below like subscribe you
know spread the word you just let us
know what you thought of the video let
us know you think about arrow what are
you loving right now
I just love to hear your thoughts on
that also on Twitter talk to Dennis
Michael myself talk to us about anything
on right now TV movies video games
comics what are you liking now we're at
think here o personally I'm at Griffin
de and we also have a Facebook page
that's facebook.com slash think hero
fans
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]